all right Thank You Anu I appreciate
that thank you for that warm welcome
that's right people we are live on
YouTube right now that's it we are a
room full of living human beings and
there are thousands of Russian BOTS
watching us right now
it's wild they're all clicking away
they're watching us right now
YouTube could actually take down this
stream at any moment so there is a
chance that this is a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity for you guys I'm very happy
you're here glad to see so many of you
guys here this issue this issue about
tech censorship and the big tech
companies and how it relates to free
speech in the First Amendment and all of
these things of course is something
that's that's close to my heart and
something that in the last four or five
years I've sort of been at the center of
I think most of you guys know I'm a big
free speech guy and obviously as someone
that puts out a YouTube show and a
podcast and all of these things that
these companies have become really the
the highways for us to communicate for
any one of you that has any clue as to
who I am it's because you found me on
youtube or on Twitter or on Facebook
that's how I'm sure many of you guys met
with each other it's how many of you
find out about any of the thinkers that
you're interested in in these days or
any of the members of the intellectual
dark web which sounds much scarier than
it actually is
and right now we're at a really
precarious moment with these companies
because they seem to be cracking down on
all dissident thought and it's not just
it's not just far-right thought it's not
just scary right-wing thought or all
right thought or whatever any of those
things actually are what we're realizing
is that more and more these things are
coming down on people that just sort of
take any position outside of what is
sort of well you could describe a sort
of mainstream kind of leftist woek
progressive I'm using a lot of buzzwords
talk right that if you just take any
position that is outside of that that
you seemingly are on the outside
of what the censorship police think is
okay so before I bring up the panelists
here tonight and we're gonna have a deep
dive for about an hour
completely uncensored on all of these
topics and sort of figure out what our
touch points are and where we differ on
some of these things I wanted to show
you a video of something that was
released this morning actually I didn't
know about this I was flying here I took
a red-eye from LA last night woke up
here in in Cleveland about 6:00 a.m. and
this video had dropped this is a video
from James O'Keefe over a project
Veritas that I'm sure many of you guys
are familiar with and what he does is he
often gets in touch with employees at
these tech companies who want to blow
the whistle on what's going on and how
these how the algorithms are being
manipulated how search is being
manipulated how their D boosting certain
articles how they how they try to add
fairness to other things which actually
screw up reality because they don't
believe that reality is actually fair
and I'm gonna show you a two-minute
video now this is with a Google engineer
talking about how they're manipulating
the YouTube search and suggested bar
that you see when you're in YouTube and
you might recognize one of the guys they
talk about so let's throw it to the
video but it was a special occasion that
happened in May and they they invited us
all to sama temple to talk about the
future of the company for YouTube and
they described that they were going to
have more content filtering and right
after that happened a lot of the content
creator started to get demonetized and
they just had to get to ranks I'm
talking about Dave Rubin talking about
carpe diem I'm talking about 10 10 pool
and a lot of the other content creators
that are within the YouTube ecosystem
just soldered the view counts just go to
so how is it that Google is able to
target its people the way that Google is
able to target people is that the
take videos and then they do a
transliteration through using artificial
intelligence specifically the insider
verified that Praeger you the
conservative educational YouTube channel
and talk show host Dave Reubens videos
received heightened analysis and the
artificial intelligence program vaya con
vaya con police's YouTube distribution
singling Prager and Ruben out as
right-wing and news talk and they looked
at the translated text of what those
people are saying and then they assigned
certain categories to them like white
year or news talk and then they're able
to take those and apply their
algorithmic we biasing unfairness
algorithms to them so that their content
is suppressed across the platform and so
they're coming in and they're throwing
their thumb down and they're deciding
which content the users are allowed to
see what's scary about this to you
what's scary is that Google's deciding
what's important and what's not
important they are going through and
they're effectively deleting
conversations from the national
narrative it reminds me of a book 1984
yeah so there you go I don't want to
upset you guys but just by being in a
room with me you're now alright so
congratulations everybody
yeah oh now you applauded that now I'm
definitely demonetized
brother that's all right so really this
issue I think is the issue of our time
because everything else that we talk
about whether we're talking about
philosophy or history or art or anything
else it's all dependent on our ability
to communicate with each other
and have these tech companies grown too
large do they control too much
information and our ability to
communicate with each other and is there
anything we can do about that so I am
going to bring up three guests we
normally only do one guest on the Reuben
port sometimes we do two you're getting
three tonight so make some noise I'm
gonna bring them all out together we've
got the chairman of the board of the
iron Rand Institute you're on Brooke
a many time Rubin report guests we have
a philosophy instructor at Rutgers
University
Greg Salieri and you better really give
this guy a round of applause because he
was a former senior engineer manager at
Facebook Bryan Amerige he worked in the
belly of the beast people all right guys
just by sitting here together we are
very scary people and the people
watching at home are being radicalized
so let's just dive into it I guess I'll
give you the most blue sky question that
I can ask first and I'll start with you
because you worked at Facebook so how
big have these companies become when we
talk about the way that they can control
information not only the videos you get
but when you search a historical figure
or event the way they can reorganize
figures or past or history anything
related to our health records all of
these things how big have these
companies actually become well I mean I
think you have to break down what big
means in that context I mean there are
lots of different dimensions you can
look at on one side they're gigantic
companies which just means they have a
huge number of people in you know just
in the first place so they've got 35,000
50,000 people and each of those
employees is responsible for millions
and millions and millions of users
effectively and so you have an
unbelievable amount of control in a
sense of what the experience is like for
many many people around the world which
is part of why people are attracted to
working there but I think you're aware
of that as as an employee of these
companies that's why you go there you go
there because even hopefully because
you're trying to make something do
something better with that but you
have to be careful I think when you're
looking at these issues not to not not
to look at that in terms of just
deciding what people see because that's
at the end of the day that's not what
these tools do you know people it's
about distribution when you're talking
about something like YouTube or Facebook
it's about what people see but at the
end of the day people decide for
themselves what they think is true and
at its best these companies are aware of
that
right so people's decide for themselves
except if they're being selected certain
information certainly manually selected
we know about algorithmic decisions but
then manually as well that's where it
becomes a problem greg is it possible
that companies like this have become too
large in that when you have 35,000
employees 50,000 employees
you simply cannot control exactly what's
going on there you're giving low-level
employees often a tremendous amount of
power to manipulate search terms and the
way these videos are distributed etc
well I think it's a tremendous challenge
to manage a large organization like that
I mean Brian can tell us a lot more
having worked in that industry it's
difficult and if the companies are too
large to handle that management
challenge then we'll see that in the
companies not providing a good product
and I think the way to correct for that
is people will come out with better
products that compete with them the only
alternative to that when we talk about
them getting too large there's the worry
of the idea that they're too large they
have to be broken up by trust-busting
regulations is what elizabeth warren
wants on the left--it what a lot of
people on the right now want and I don't
think that there's any size that company
can get where that's Lauren did because
all you're saying then is who's really
in charge of these decisions is the
government and if largeness was a
problem
the government's larger than any of
these companies but I don't think
largeness in the end is is this
intractable problem it's just a
management problem of finding out how to
get a good policy how to come up with a
policy that scales how to get your
people to enforce it it's difficult but
it's a problem that needs to be solved
either by the people working at the
current major tech company
to improve their product or by companies
that will come up and replacing yeah I
think it's interesting that you brought
up how the left and the right right now
are agreeing seemingly agreeing or at
least a large portion we're agreeing on
this premise that they have to be broken
up so you have Elizabeth Warren saying
they have to be broken up that seems to
be in line with most progressive
policies but right now you have a ton of
conservatives and I'm even seeing it
from some libertarians who are saying
that the power that they control is so
awesome the amount of information that
they know about us
is so epic and out of control that we
want regulation and it's it's always
interesting to me because I see this a
lot from the Trump people let's say the
mag of people who feel like they're the
outsiders right and it's like alright
you're gonna hand that power to Trump
and maybe in the short term Trump does
some things that are good for you and
the platform's become a little more fair
but a short-sighted game right because
then if Trump's out of office
you've now handed that power over to say
the progressive side and now they've got
the president and they've got tech and
now you have a bigger problem on your
hand well in it but it's more than that
it's it's your granny the government now
power to decide not only of a size sheis
I so-called monopolies that's bad enough
we can talk about that but now you're
giving them the discretion of deciding
when does some form of discrimination
about content when is that okay and when
it is not and that is huge power that is
power over speech that is a clear
violation of free speech when the
government starts to make those kind of
decisions and you write when the right
is in they'll decide it one way in the
left is and they'll decide another way
but it's the fact that we giving
government that power and it won't stop
with social media I mean one of the
things that I think I think gets lost in
this is the the fact that it is the fact
that you know the one hand we think of
these companies as as controlling what
we see and how much in all this
information that we receive but think
about what it was like I don't know 60
years ago but 60 years ago there was
like two encyclopedias you got your
history you had everything from a bunch
of people who wrote to encyclopedias and
you think they weren't biased
were they you know of course they were
biased in many of them were academics
with a bit certain political reflection
and they wrote encyclopedias in a
particular way and there was just too
and then on top of that there was some
news well there were three television
stations if you go back and read
conservative media in the 1960s they
thought the three media stations three
television stations were all radically
left and they probably were and and when
Ronald Reagan ran for president all
three television stations were clearly
against him as was every new almost
every newspaper in the country he won in
spite of that so the history is such
that it's always been the case that that
uh you know the news we get the
information we get us being very
restricted indeed I believe we live in a
time where we have more sources of
information more avenues more ability to
get different points of view than ever
in all of human history it's never been
less controlled so in spite of the size
of Facebook because there's still some
competition and because the stone
newspapers and it's still television
it's still a few other things you've got
so much more source of information than
ever in human history and I don't think
I think it's important not to lose that
perspective yeah so I definitely want to
dive more into whether regulation could
work and I absolutely think that the
four of us agree that that's really not
look I always tell people it's like I
pay my California state taxes on a
California state website which looks
like prodigy in 1999 yeah that's why you
moved to Puerto Rico
I remember prodigy that's how old I am
but okay but before we talk more about
sort of regulation or the or the
platform burrs publisher debate which i
think is a really interesting one Brian
can you just talk a little bit more
about the culture at a place like
Facebook because I think that's what
people are really worried about that
even if you can accept Iran's premise
that we have more access to information
than ever before and all of those things
that sort of when you have these
companies that are so the culture there
seemingly is about conforming to a
certain set of ideas
how that actually affects the output in
the work sure I mean it's it changed a
lot over time you know I joined in 2012
and at that point in time you know
Facebook was essentially in a political
place internally it was ruthlessly
focused on the mission of the company
which was to make the world more open
and connected it was an unbelievably
healthy culture internally in terms of
the ability to debate different points
of view and to challenge people who are
above you in the hierarchy
it was very non hierarchical and a
census as close to a meritocracy I think
you could get in a company so I think
it's very healthy at that point in time
things did start to change I think
around 2015 2016 you know particularly
when Donald Trump secured like the the
Republican nomination what what happened
was you know I think in general the
world became a little bit more
politicized or in we just started
spending more time on that it became
identity politics as run us up into this
place where it became more of who we
think of who we are and one of these
things we had inside Facebook culturally
was this this sort of goal of bringing
your authentic self to work and what
that meant was that there was no
separation between your sort of
professional life and your personal life
it was we want you to be your whole self
at Facebook and that makes a lot of
sense when you're building a product
that is so personal like you you need to
be able to accommodate and tailor and
deal with the complexity of people on a
personal level and you need to deal with
that level of complexity when you're
building the product if you if you're
expecting people to trust and to share
and to bring their authentic self into
the product and so that made a lot of
sense from a product perspective but the
combination of those two things where
we're saying okay everybody you know
there is no distinction between
professional and personal bring your
whole self to work and everybody is
getting a little bit more political
meant that politics came to work more
and more if you started becoming you
know these political discussions and you
know he's because this culture where you
could put any poster you want up on the
wall for for the causes and issues that
you care about most of them were focus
on the product and the mission and
things like that but not all of them
were and the sheer demographics of the
company it's in Silicon Valley it's it
is overwhelmingly left-leaning meant
that that was sort of the you know the
the Trinity I suppose of a perfect storm
for the far left leaning politics to
kind of come into the company and you
know not there were a number of key
events that like made it really clear
that that was happening you know the
just there's a QA that happens every
Friday with mark so the whole company
can sort of just line up and ask
questions to mark about what you know
his thoughts on where the company's
going or doing different conditions and
going on in the marketplace and those
questions themselves started becoming
more political in nature you know and we
started getting questions like you know
hey Peter teal is supports Donald Trump
and he's on our board of directors why
are we okay with that so there and the
tone of those questions started
increasingly becoming political it
became increasingly direct about the
fact that you know of course we feel
this way and this way happens to be some
socially less cleaning point the funny
part of bringing up teal is that
everything that these guys talk about is
about diversity and yet teal was the
only one who probably still is the only
one really out there yeah I mean in fact
as far as I understand that's that's one
of his primary values as a board member
is that he's often the most far-out
there when nobody else has any ideas
about how to do something he usually
does so yeah it was definitely ironic so
you know you started getting more of
those kinds of questions you start
seeing these posters black lives matter
or up on the wall resist is up on the
wall you see Obama hope poster is up on
the wall and then a couple other things
happen that made it really clear that
the culture was changing so what do you
think
to conservatives or libertarians or
anyone sort of rightly named that they
really seemingly have gotten cowered
into silence because I do think a lot of
this discussion is framed around the
fact that there's a certain set of views
that were made
you know mainstream sort of Ronald
Reagan political views say twenty years
ago but now that you say them they're
thought of as sort of far-right like the
right is really sort of it's it's been
cowed I think by the blatant use or the
overuse of racist homophobic bigot I
don't think it it's I don't think of
politics is on that kind of a right-left
spectrum where what we could think of is
like the current politics is way to the
left of Reagan and things that were as
right as Reagan where are now its far
right we're playing a video game here I
know it's because you have to do so you
have to go issue by issue if you think
about I'll say why this is but if you
think about for example Reagan on trade
well Reagan's view on trade is pretty
similar to Obama's view on trade and
Clinton's view on trade and Carter's
view on trade Trump's view on trade is
way different from that and something
that used to be associated with the far
left
if you look on race issues and
immigration issues right Reagan was very
Pro immigration he did an amnesty and
was celebrated for that so it's there
are some issues where Reagan's positions
are now considered far-right there are
some where they're now considered laughs
and it's because these concepts left and
right don't really mean much and they
shift moment to moment with the
political winds what I do think is the
good things about Reagan and I don't
think a freaking there's any kind of
hero but the good things in him were the
defense of capitalism the being Pro free
markets to the limited extent that he
was the being assertive of America as
some kind of ideal of freedom
particularly in its rhetoric about the
Soviet Union those kinds of things I
think insofar as the right holds on to
them they don't have the kind of moral
defence needed for them and so they
don't know what to say
they're challenged but the sadder thing
is and in a way this is Reagan's legacy
I think those issues have been
supplanted on the right by other issues
so there are free marketers but what's
it the ascendancy on the right these
days are religionists and an
anti-immigration ist's and those people
aren't what would have been called
conservatives in the in the 60s
they're not the kind of view that I'm in
favor of and I think those people are
part of the problem I mean those views
are inherently tribalist excit kinds of
views they're not views that really come
from a place of principle and so if
that's what's animating you I think it's
hard to talk about principle and if
you're the minority then you you have
that view when you're the minority and
the other view is a leftist view all
you're gonna be able to do is rage
against the other people and feel put
upon the same way that the leftist feel
put upon in corporate cultures that are
different from theirs and you're not
going to be able to have a kind of
self-confident principled debate about
what's happening so I there's a lot to
blame on the left here too but I think
the lack of ideas and the lack of being
about something principled has really
been poisoned to the right to that point
[Music]
that everything has to be political all
the time you should bring your full self
to work so that you can be actualized
enough and that does your politics
become part of your work the companies
that I mean every commercial that we
from Gillette to Sephora to Nike
everything has some sort of social
justice or intersectional angle to it
and that it's leaving us sort of with no
space to realize Wow we live in a
country of 320 320 somewhat million
people and that and the differences are
actually okay well I mean the left is
for a long time being arguing that
everything is political and that
everything must be political that arts
the essential essential feature of art
is politics that's the theme of our
conference here is art that art is
essentially political that every action
that you take is political and imbued
with political meaning and let's the
left as one intellectual debate I mean
we can talk about or there's a reason
why Facebook is dominated by people of
the left is a reason why YouTube is
dominated by people it's because they
want they won the universities they
dominate the universities they've won
the intellectual debate yes there's a
populist anti leftist movement but it's
populist is anti intellectual it's non
intellectual but the left has won that
debate and has influenced the culture
and the culture has become more
politicized everything now is framed in
terms of politics and ultimately now
it's become it's framed in which tribe
you belong to which group you belong to
not just an ideology because ideology
seems to have gone because your ideology
is framed by which group you belong to
right so it's it's all now group
politics and you know if I'm running a
large corporation you know and you don't
have solid principles and you don't have
solid ideas what do you do you you've
got huge amount of pressure from the
left notice that the the left is very
active right it has whole committees to
identify ads that might not be
intersectional enough or whatever the
hell that means you know it might not be
politically correct enough and they put
pressure on companies they're very very
active you know the the the people of
Pro free markets certainly have not been
that active in the past you know too
busy making money is is a big part of it
but too busy living but the left a views
everything is political be is willing to
put the reefs
and the efforts and the energy and the
action into trying to sway the culture
and sway these companies and your CEO
and you're getting pressure from this
group and they're yelling at you and
they're going to your body to your
shareholder meetings and they're trying
to place people on your board of
directors and they're rallying their
people to boycott your product or
whatever it's a huge amount of pressure
for unprincipled you know for somebody
who doesn't have a huge backbone a
really strong backbone not to resist and
not to succumb and I think what you're
seeing is company after company
succumbing and in doing what you know
what the pressure to be doing there's a
there's a huge moral guilt issue that
I've also seen like it's hugely rampant
inside Facebook where the company is
unbelievably successful and you know
frankly I don't think many people inside
the company understand why and I don't
think that they stand tall as they
should and have pride in what they've
created and the value it creates for the
world and so what happens when you're
unbelievably unprecedented ly successful
and you don't really understand why and
you're not as proud as you ought to be
and what you've created is that when
these groups come to you and they claim
oh you're hurting me in this way you're
hurting me in that way you you bow down
to it I mean you want to help you want
to help the little guy you want to give
back so - so to speak
and so I think that that often wins and
this is what we've been teaching in
business schools we'd be teaching
corporate social responsibility for
decades we'd be teaching stakeholder
capitalism yet don't Aksumite
shareholder walls don't make money
that's not what you're about what you're
really about is appeasing all these
stakeholders so now a stakeholders
coming to you a powerful stakeholder
with a big voice and a mall voice and
saying you can't do this do something
else it's easy to succumb because of the
guilt and it's also consistent with what
you study in a business school well that
one I find just that personal level so
interesting because I am NOT a
shareholder
I am a creator on YouTube and when they
demonetised my videos because I talked
about I mean I'm pretty sure something
like six of the first eight clips that I
ever did with you
were demonetized this radical but one of
the things that I always think about is
okay look as a private company they can
do whatever they want when it comes to
demonization they don't have to offer my
channel monetization in the first place
they don't have to offer me that service
and by the way they always acknowledge
this they give us tremendous technology
to do literally what we're doing right
now I'm not paying anything for this
live stream this is going out hopefully
to hundreds of thousands and millions of
people absolutely for free so I it's
funny when I when I rail against YouTube
it's because I want it to work better
and I feel if I use my voice that would
be better than then using government
force let's say but but it's interesting
to beyond the shareholder part of it
because it seems that if they were
trying to maximize profits if that's
what they're really there to do as
opposed to do good or whatever some of
these catchphrases are well you'd want
to put ads on every video out there and
and maybe there are some things that are
really too extreme or certain things
that are illegal for it you know an Isis
recruiting video you don't want on your
platform but beyond that that you would
have a simple set of rules that says
we're gonna treat everyone else fairly
and this I think will also get us into
the platform verses publisher part of
this conversation which i think is
interesting but wouldn't that make the
most sense just purely if a business was
operating the way a business is supposed
to wouldn't that make the most sense to
let people put up content we're gonna
advertise it and if it's illegal you
can't put it on our platform and we're
good I mean first of all I think a lot
of these companies have bought into the
stakeholder social responsibility kind
of mantra so they don't just maximize
shareholder wealth I wish they did and I
wish they would be proud of it and stand
up for it because that's means that
creating value but creating pop profit
is a signal of
you it's a symbol of value shareholder
wealth means you're creating wealth new
wealth you're creating something
incredibly valuable out there but it's
not obvious to me right take for example
the lots of TV shows take television for
a minute and some companies choose to
advertise on some shows and other
companies choose to advertise on other
shows and there's certain places where
there's no advertising and and nobody
nobody wants to advertise on them and it
could be that my sing you know the the
segments I did advertisers would rather
not advertise there I don't know right I
don't know how YouTube decides these
things and how much communication there
is with advertisers in terms of these
things it could be that advertisers that
the companies behind are saying we don't
want right-wing stuff or we don't want a
Objectivist stuff or I doubt it but but
the lack of transparency is part of the
problem right that's you're not Malala
talk tell me what the rules are give me
give me a consistent set of rules and we
can either play to those rules or not
play to those rules I wouldn't change my
content but I would I would say all
right I'm gonna have your on Brooke on
today we know that's not gonna make any
money and we have to you know fundraise
and in some other fashion listen I agree
completely I mean the biggest problem I
see with all of these platforms in terms
of is that they're not transparent in
terms of what they're doing so we don't
know what they're doing we can't plan as
creatives we can't plan how to relate to
them and and in terms of monetization
which is so crucial to somebody who's
building a business around this you
don't know what's gonna be monetized on
that I you know a lot of my videos go up
and immediately they're not gonna be
monetized the the algorithm has said
it's not monetized and I click on you
know review please have a human being
review this and almost all of them
almost all of them not all of them get
monetized afterwards right a human being
looks at them and said oh well it's not
that way but if I knew what was causing
this to go one way or another I could
adjust I could I could decide how to how
to [ __ ] how to do this but I think I
think a lot of the rules that they send
us you know we sign these contracts
these Terms of Service and they're
complicated and we don't know what's in
it and it's hedged so that it gives them
no --mess and i would you don't have
your personal
lawyer review those contracts for you
when you sign up for these things you
don't have your guy on retainer looking
through the 50 pages I probably should
have but no none of us have and every
time you have to click on a website that
says the you can't do it it's not it's
not feasible and so it would be good I
think one of the things that that I
think hopefully new platforms that
ultimately compete with these do is is
if they're gonna have certain
restrictions that they are transparent
about them and they have some mechanism
maybe to even challenge the decision
maybe maybe some kind of arbitration a
way to arbitrate these disputes but
right now it's opaque from the
perspective producer you don't know you
just have no look I think you have to
keep in mind what a tremendous technical
challenge these companies are facing and
business challenge and product challenge
and that being transparent is part of
that I mean 20 years ago none of this
stuff existed now I was talking to an
engineer who works at Google in the you
tradition earlier today he was telling
me it's 500 minutes of video a minute
can upload it to YouTube I mean imagine
the kinds of decisions that go into
figuring out how to do that they don't
have a rulebook they didn't realize
ahead of time how big the issue of
politicization on the platform was going
to be maybe they should have they
weren't but they weren't prepared for it
they're trying to figure out what the
rules should be in real time they don't
have the philosophical ammunition to do
it in the background to do it and that's
a failure of the intellectuals in the
culture of articulating the principles
they need but here these people are out
to sea having created this tremendous
thing trying to patch holes as they're
sailing you know and if they had some
and they're changing I mean it's we
talked about on that video a change that
happened in YouTube in their algorithms
in May and I'm sure that did happen but
there are I was also talking this
YouTube engineer how often is the Google
algorithm was changed it's like well
hundreds of times a day probably they're
constantly changing how they do things
and they have to be when they don't have
it figured out it's hard for them to be
transparent about what they're doing so
I think
they should it would be a much better
product if there was that transparency
and hopefully eventually they'll be able
to either evolve to that or be replaced
by better product but it's a real
accomplishment to get there and we've
gotten there yet so Brian I'm starting
to think that there's sort of an emperor
has no clothes feeling to all of this
that actually the companies themselves
because they have grown so large don't
fully know what's going on with the
algorithm is that just a naive way of
looking at how engineers deal with this
that's absolutely true that's very oh
[ __ ] yeah so I mean just a little
insight on how in terms of what makes it
hard to be transparent and a little bit
about how these algorithms work whether
it's you know ranking and newsfeed or or
D monetization on YouTube so what they
don't have is some sort of band list of
you know if you talk about these topics
or you use these words you know with
your if you're an Objectivist or you're
on the the write that you're gonna fall
into this category and we're gonna treat
you this way that's not how it works so
what's essentially happening and for
this is true for both YouTube and
Facebook on the you know the talk about
D monetization for example what they're
trying to insulate advertisers from is
the risk of their brands being tarnished
by controversy that's that's the thing
that advertisers are worried about
they're worried about the fact that if
they are associated with something
that's considered hateful or hate speech
or politically incorrect that that's
going to blow up it's going to tarnish
their brand that's going to be they
don't want to be associated with that is
that a very strange thing though because
I don't think say before the internet if
you were watching any NBC sitcom you you
weren't thinking that whoever at you
know tied endorsed that particular
episode of The Cosby Show or something
like that I think people have become a
lot more sensitive about it and they
become much more they become more
activist like about it in saying like oh
you're right next to that ad therefore
you know we're gonna try to punish you
and control you in this way and so what
I've understood from the advertisers and
you know I didn't work on that part
directly but I've spoken to hoaxes
inside Facebook about this is that
that's essentially their concern it's
not that they have any you know they're
against it Objectivist or they're
against people on the right
it's that they they don't want to be
associated with something that could
become controversial and so the problem
for these companies becomes how do we
predict what's going to become
controversial and the way you do that is
not that you have a team of human beings
who are deciding what's controversial
it's not the answer is that you build
fairly sophisticated models using
artificial intelligence and machine
learning that essentially try to predict
what's going to be controversial and
what's not okay so without going to
matrix right now aren't the humans the
flaw in the system they're I mean these
systems are built by humans who have
their own biases and all that I mean I
look at it from a higher level than that
like I think the flaw is what you were
saying in the sense of like you can't be
that sensitive about being associated
with with content that's controversial
because it is it is impossible to build
models that are going to predicts this
stuff accurately what those models end
up predicting like nobody can even tell
you you might look at it from a very
human perspective and say like oh it
kind of fuzz idli looks like they're
biased against conservatives or
Objectivists or you know whatever it is
but in practice the way these models
work is there are hundreds of thousands
of levers nobody knows what they all are
they're trained essentially with
datasets that are and again they're
trying to reduce controversy and
essentially with them and that's the
advertiser concern at least and that's
where it's coming from but there's no
sort of ban list on far-right or things
like so right I guess the issue is that
what is considered dangerous seemingly
always is going in one direction so it's
not that it's all far-right it's just
anything that sort of you know 20 years
ago was thought of as mainstream say
conservative thought now that is thought
of as dangerous but all right let's talk
a little bit about some of the some of
the potential solutions in competition
and regulation and things like that one
of the more compelling arguments that
I've heard is that if we treated these
companies like public utilities that
everyone could have access so you know
sort of the way you get water at your
house or the phone that what you say on
the phone doesn't mean that they
can you know take your phone line away
they can arrest you if you're doing
something illegal or something like that
but beyond that that we all have access
to to the machinery do you guys find
that compelling in any way great I don't
and I think it's coming from a kind of
false view of what this technology is in
the first place that it was somehow
neutral until people started putting
their fingers on the scale so like five
years ago YouTube was neutral as to what
it showed you there is no way to
organize the world's information
neutrally the whole idea of organizing
the world's information is making
judgements judgements powered by
algorithms that algorithms written by
people and constantly tweaked by people
to see what things are gonna be most
important what things are we gonna
feature over which how are we going to
tell what kind of connections are we
going to prioritize over which it's a
very complex problem of ranking
information to say what we should
promote what we're gonna try to sell to
the guy who just watch what little be on
the watch next list
what will autocomplete when you write in
your things at Google what will the
first results will be that stuff has
never been neutral and it's always being
it has to be by its nature tuned some
way or other and what we have is there's
always going to be disagreements
necessarily about how to tune it people
are going to have different ideas and
when you have a government controlling
that tuning that's when you have
censorship that's when you have one
person with a gun with the power to stop
any competitors from arising in charge
of what information we get shared and
what gets shown to us when you have a
company doing it no matter how big that
company isn't no matter how it might be
failing in doing it there's the all
kinds of pressures on them to try to do
better to try to please more of the
demographics who are gonna want to use
it and there's abilities that whole
capital markets kind of funding them to
startup alternatives to it and it's not
like before the recent change because
there was this change that caused a lot
of problems for your channel right but
it's not like prior to that change
everything in YouTube was perfect so if
it was the case for example that the
watch next list as this kind of alarmist
Times article was talking about
leaving people if they just clipped
through after your videos to get to some
really kind of Nazi as content or
something that that's not a good thing
either that's not what you know you
would hope would be shown to your
viewers next after you there was
something not good about the algorithm
it was fixed in another not good way and
no one knows the one there is no neutral
way to fix it and no one knows what the
best way is to fix it
that's got to be learned by people
training it out and competing on a
market it can't be dictated by the top
and if we try to dictate it by the top
well we're going to get is the kind of
media environment that people now
satisfies but which was really bad the
kind we had in the 50s 60s 70s people
talk about now you know back then you
didn't know what Ted Koppel thought he
was neutral and so forth that's [ __ ]
he wasn't neutral he had a certain point
of view it was a very blinkered narrow
left-leaning point of view and just
nobody knew that it wasn't the only
point of view out because he didn't have
any way to get any other information
only the real radicals who read
underground publications that knew the
other points of view now everyone knows
the other point of view so they're
annoyed at the predominant one and
that's better than it used to be so for
those of you that might have missed
there one of the references that Greg
made their last Sunday in the New York
Times there was a front page cover story
that had pictures of about 40 youtubers
and it was about radicalization to the
far right and the alt-right by YouTube
and my picture was included in there and
Ben Shapiro and Jordan Peterson and
radicals like Milton Friedman because a
lot of people to the phone right but I
think it's interesting because you we
get hit with this this is not just about
tech companies it's also about the media
it's it's about all of these things and
it's interesting because in this article
the idea was that YouTube somehow has
game the system so if you watch my video
it takes you to scary Petersons too
scary or Shapiro's and then to evil
Friedman and that you're going to become
far-right or something but in fact by
that video that we we just watched here
that two-minute clip in fact YouTube has
decided that if you watch my videos
they're gonna recommend msn
so if anything there radicalizing people
in a far scarier way in my estimation
with nobody should be watching that yeah
that's where the other clause there you
go
I went for an MSNBC joke there instead
of a CNN joke that was weird but but
even that it's like well I know that the
tech reporters at the New York Times are
not gonna follow up now and go oh we
actually got this thing completely wrong
so this is not just about tech it's also
about media but this is why I said
before this is about the broader culture
this is about the fact that the left is
one the cultural war in that sense in
the sense of setting the intellectual
you know framework for what we what we
discuss they dominate the New York Times
they dominate you know the regular
television station they you know even
Tucker Coulson now isn't dost pretty
much Elizabeth Wan so you know the left
has the moral high ground it dominates
our universities and by dominating
universities it dominates all these
other things so fixing the tech stuff is
not gonna change anything the people
will care tech are still gonna be
overwhelmingly on the left even if you
break up these companies all these
little companies most of them a
predominant number of them are gonna be
run by leftist right so there's no easy
fix for any of these issues in terms of
what we're concerned about is the
dominant of the left in in in media in
the intellectual world the only way to
deal with that is to challenge them and
replace them on the intellectual high
ground I want to say something about
public utilities cuz I'm against the
whole concept right I I don't think
there is such a thing I think it denies
the fact that everything is is created
by somebody and somebody had a property
right over it and the state came in and
stole that property and took it over and
turned it into a public utility it was
unjust when they did it to electrical
companies way back when it's unjust when
they did it to telecommunication
companies in the beginning of time and
then they freed them up a little bit and
and you know and it would be unjust if
we suddenly determined that that any
other platform was now so-called public
utility it's unjust to the creators so
the people who built it to the people
who made it it's their property
and property rights are not a minor
little detail property rights at the
heart of all individual rights that the
heart of what it means to have a right
to your own life so then what would you
say about sort of the now not just MSNBC
it's yeah there you go
what would you say then to the argument
this sort of platform versus publisher
argument which is another one that I
find at least compelling at some level
which is that if you're a publisher so
if you're a network let's take you know
Shapiro's Daily wire for example if they
write something that's libelous Ben and
the rest of the company they're they're
responsible for what is on there their
specific platform as opposed to a
wide-ranging platform where we are the
creators and they have different sort of
legal responsibilities where they're not
supposed to be choosing what can be seen
what can't be seen making political
decisions related to advertising things
of that nature do you find any
compelling argument around that this is
Ted Cruz has been promulgating this and
I forget the name someone tried to pass
a law on this idea recently uh I don't
find it compelling and I think it's a
real distortion of what publisher and
platform means if if you can only think
of there's two kinds of things there's a
totally even that makes no thought goes
into and no algorithms determine what
shows up somehow magically it's all fair
by someone's conception of fairness on
the one hand and a book publisher on the
other and you think those are the only
two things in the universe and then you
see Facebook or YouTube you might be
worried about which bucket they go into
but that's not the way the universe
works
what there's all kinds of organizations
that are neither of those things and
it's pretty clear once you see and
there's no organization that's allegedly
fair in this way that means everything
somehow magically equally gets
represented that's not even possible
but if you think of all the kinds of
organizations there are lecture halls
that rent out their Hall to different
people to speak about different topics
and they don't select who they're going
to put on they're not a promoter they're
just a left
but maybe they think we wouldn't have
this guy there colleges that let people
speak at them libraries that have book
clubs and you could have a book club at
the library parks at like different
people speak at them and bulletin boards
and someone runs a bullet literal
physical you know bits of cork up
somewhere and someone puts things up and
takes them down and book shops which
have different books they didn't publish
the books but they sell them right all
of those things or none of those kinds
of things are subject to libel laws or
have been subject to libel laws as far
as I know they are all way more like
what Facebook and Google are then then
our publishers so I think this is not by
everyone who's repeating it but by the
people who started I think this is a
clever dishonest argument I think it's a
way to destroy the concept of publisher
in people's minds and make it include
basically everything so that we could
have control over basically everyone I
think it's a really powerless ting dark
kind of thing that's going on in
politics
so then as the guy that worked at one of
these tech companies and left did you
just feel it was untenable there was
nothing that one guy could do well what
I saw was that it whether there's a gun
pointed them pointed at them or not for
them to be better in one way or another
they're never going to be good at this
these companies and these products
whether you're talking about YouTube or
Twitter or Facebook they're not built
for ideas you know Facebook was built to
bring you closer to your friends and
family to keep you know to keep you
up-to-date on what's going on with with
organizations who care about and the
people you care about
you know and YouTube was essentially
built to bring you entertaining videos
and the way what they're built to do and
what they're great at is optimizing for
engagement in that sense optimizing for
sort of social closeness in the Facebook
sense that is a very different
optimization function than what's
thoughtful or what's a different point
of view or what's going to help you
learn about a complex or controversial
issue
they're just categorically different
things and it doesn't matter what you
try to do to get the employee base that
have rallied around Facebook's mission
or YouTube's mission it doesn't matter
how you try to get them to do it they're
not gonna be good at building that kind
of platform for ideas it's not why
they're there it's not what they
understand
I think it's outside of their wheelhouse
and so and that's why I left I left
because it doesn't matter what happens
after this they're never going to build
that thing that I want so deeply which
is that platform for ideas so as the guy
who was mentioned by The Insider and I'm
feeling a certain crunch on this and
dealing with the the D monetization and
the rest of it I've said this publicly
many times it's pushing so on the ideal
level here I really am with you guys I
do not want the government does not do
anything well I do not want the
government involved in this as I said
the idea that they could come in and run
tech companies when they can't run their
own websites is ridiculous to me but it
is pushing that sort of libertarian side
of me too
to its limit it does feel like it's
gonna snap and I would be example what I
would give is let's say right now as
we're watching this someone at YouTube's
going well I don't really wanted to see
this so we can throttle the video down
and you know what someone else is going
to know you already throttled it why
don't we just cut the stream altogether
and then someone else is going well why
don't we just delete his channel
altogether and then someone else says
why don't we do that on Twitter and
someone else says alright let's do it on
Facebook and they can in effect
digitally assassinate you now I
understand none of these things are a
blatant some sort of criminal event but
they do seem in the in the world that
we're going in they do seem like a
digital assassination that we need to
think about a little bit differently and
the last thing I'll say before I throw
to you is I just know that there's a
huge amount of people watching this
right now going okay you guys can talk
about ideas up till you're all blue in
the head but they're coming for you
you're and you're sitting there watch
you know talking about ideas and I and I
mean myself to here but what do you
think the best response well first is
this is when principles matter it's easy
to be principled and believe in ideas
when everything is smooth and
everything's nice and you have nothing
at stake but if the principle of
property rights if the principle that
the government shouldn't intervene in
free speech should monitor shouldn't
decide what's okay and what's not if
that principle is the right principle
and I truly believe it is then yeah it
sometimes we're gonna have to fight for
it under conditions that are high
tonight and I get why it's hard for you
right I mean they're after you they're
attacking you but this is when it counts
well it didn't count a few years ago
what difference does it make right
because it was easy right of course you
were for that principle so now is the
time to Stanford and I think and I think
that there's another issue here did it's
I think we should be condemning them
orally if truly somebody is there
turning down and and disturb disrupting
the stream then we could say this is
wrong this is a that I mean we know it I
mean that's what that video is about
that's not the Machine didn't do that by
itself they have decided to put
information into the machine so we
condemn and the beauty of it is that if
50 years ago they'd be in a New York
Times article about you that described
you in this way
they were for example about iron ranch
and and and saying without what a
horrible philosophy about how there was
very few mechanisms by which he could
defend herself said she could present
her ideas I mean it's interesting you
can use YouTube to attack you too and
they still let you do that
so we need to stand up we need to speak
up we when these things happen we need
to make people aware of it now
Brian could be right this won't matter
that they can't do it and and I'm
sympathetic to that but they can they
can be worth so they could be better at
a certain spectrum we can we can have an
impact rally your audience you've got a
massive audience rally them against this
but don't invite true censorship which
would be government intervention that
would be real censorship that would be
the use of force that would be their use
of coercion that would be true violation
of Rights let's rally mala Lee against
these companies when they do bad things
and and point them out and bring them
into the sunlight as as some of these
videos have done and it let's get people
let's hit people where maybe even maybe
even let's let's have some people go to
shareholder media and say I'd love to
I'd love if some organization did this
some day let's go to shareholder
meetings and say we want you to maximize
shareholder well if that is your
fiduciary duty in the law to maximize
shareholder wealth and you're not
maximizing shareholder wealth by doing
this and this and this of this stop it
and the left does it all the time the
left is excellent at doing this and
guilting them at using you know social
responsibility of stakeholders or
whatever it is let's use the right stuff
not from the right but right stuff to
really go after these guys and and and
and try to convince these companies to
behave better and just better until what
I think is the ultimate solution which
is alternatives to them does some of
this team sort of
the some of this sort of seemed
inevitable to you that we had sort of a
golden age of the internet where we
didn't really know what it was we didn't
know what we were walking around with in
our pocket we had access to the world
everyone was on every platform we signed
up for every new social media site then
you realize there were all sorts of bad
actors on there or whatever it was and
you know you see now there's a big push
back people canceling Facebook accounts
I take weekends off social media
altogether I do August off the grid
which I want to get more people to be
involved at that there's this is just
sort of the next step in what the
internet it is that we're starting to
after 20 years or so we sort of know
what it is now and that may be the next
version is that platforms can't survive
for all of these reasons I mean for what
it's worth that's always how it's felt
inside Facebook look we have no idea
what we're doing that should be the
company tagline we work I mean and I
mean I don't mean that in a derogatory
you know
sense I mean what Facebook has done is
unprecedented like to have a community
of almost two and a half billion people
that is you know where people can
actually connect with each other where
you can have an idea and get it out into
the entire world people with no money no
power no connection to the media have
the capability to do that that's a
complicated thing it's it especially
when you throw human beings into it it
gets even more complicated there's no
recipe book for this Facebook wasn't
created by you know mimicking any other
business and so you know I say that in a
joking way but I actually have a lot of
respect for the company in that sense
and that they're real pioneers and
innovators in figuring out how to make
this work and so that's a good thing and
a bad thing you have to give them a
little bit of slack for that but you
know I think holding them accountable
for what you want as a user is also
important the other thing I just to go
back to this point of you know this is
pushing your libertarian principles you
know I think you've got to take a
long-term view on this stuff like it
especially for you I'm sure this the
euphy
the heat on this every single day but if
you just zoom out for a second like we
haven't had that long with this issue so
far it's it's only been you know I'd say
it's been a couple years now it's
unprecedented it's gonna take a while to
figure out whether that's these
companies figuring it out which i think
is unlikely or its competition coming
and actually offering something that
serves people better that takes time
because these issues are so complicated
and because it is unprecedented in a way
and you have to give it time and what
happens I think if you don't take the
long-term view on this if we just say
well you know this hurts right now and
so we're gonna try to fix what we've got
right now is we're gonna prohibit the
ability for all that competition to come
you know I'm you know I'm working on
some of that stuff since since leaving
Facebook and what I can tell you for
sure is that if I wake up one morning
and there's a law that's passed that
governs how my future company is gonna
have to moderate content that's it we're
done that's that's the end of that
business at that point in time and so
you know I think you've got to take a
long-term view on if you want where it's
you know what I'm doing or what any of
the myriad of other folks are doing in
this space if you want that stuff to
have a chance of surviving we've got to
take the heat for a little while so is
the lesson really that human ingenuity
is sort of always the answer you know
I'm working on something as well I'm
working on a couple things actually and
I've really come around I can't say too
much right the second but I've come
around to the belief that sort of small
will be the new big that we went big on
everything you know we we bundled
everything and everybody and I think the
next version of this is sort of an
unbundling and making things smaller and
figuring out how to what type of people
we want to have associations with and of
course that will come with massive risks
because we don't want to end up in our
own echo chambers and and that sort of
thing but that this all feels like just
sort of the next the next step in this
evolution as scary as that might be for
those of us that make our living doing
this and you know it's not fun waking up
and you know
your name in the New York Times when
they're doing that sort of thing that's
a trend for what it's worth like within
social media today I mean it's very much
so if you're working at one of these
companies one of the things you've got
in the forefront of your mind is that
social media is fragmenting you know it
for good reason for network effects it
starts with these massive networks that
sort of do everything but as they mature
and they get older with time and it gets
more complicated and you get you know
lots of different use cases it makes
sense to specialize and so you know
Instagram in a big way within Facebook
is seen is taking over a lot of the
friend content that used to be on
Facebook as Facebook has sort of evolved
into more of this news consumption
public perspective kind of kind of
content but you know you see things like
next door for example taking over a lot
of neighborhood content that you know
never really did all that well on
Facebook but now it has a real home and
that company is doing you know pretty
damn well
so the fragmentation of social media at
this point in time I think is happening
and I think one of the next big
fragments is going to be ideas and and I
you know I think there's a reason why
some of the CEOs of the big tech
companies are talking about regulation
and encouraging it and partially because
they have the money to deal with it
they're gonna hire the lawyers and now
hire the compliance officers and they'll
deal with it but Brian doesn't have the
money to deal with it and you don't have
the money to deal with it you're gonna
be crushed by whatever regulation come
and the more we encourage government to
come in the less chance there is for
this to evolve because this is an
evolution it's the markets take time to
solve problems and that you know there
used to be you know automobiles in the
first 10 20 years we're not very good
and there were a lot of accidents and
and and bad stuff happened and it takes
time for us to develop better products
that a better fit for customers that
work better for customers and you need
to allow and this is why freedom so
important you need to entrepreneurs that
this face to think think outside that
box thinks new and and then to exercise
and I thought to manifest it in reality
without some governor oversight and some
long book of regulations that's how you
kill innovation how you kill an industry
and now you kill thought human thought
just disappears once the government step
said because it's stepping in it's not
benign it's stepping in with a gun
government is a gun in it guns
appropriate in some context of
self-defense but when they come in and
say you have to do it this way otherwise
here's the gun it stops
progress and that's what's at risk here
if we if we hand us over to a
governmental solution the word about a
word about in the present context
morally judging these companies and
about what we can do in the face of this
until the new companies come up for the
president want to change their policies
first of all when we were judging them
we have to keep in mind that the guns
they're already Zuckerberg was dragged
and under threat of subpoena to testify
in Congress they already know that laws
are coming one way or the other the left
and the right are ganged up against them
all they have to do is put aside hitting
each other for a few minutes to pass a
law that will throughout all of these
companies so they're already that they
know this is coming in a situation where
it's very hard to think independently
you're already under threat so we have
to take that into account in evaluating
them second they have to take into
account when morally evaluating them
that almost all of the news we get on
this and I include in this things like
Veritas are really non objective in
skewed it's hard to know what the
perspective is and you know everything
that's going on
they are always caught in some way to
make it seem either great or horrible
and it's hard to put it in perspective
so I don't know I could imagine a thing
that could have gone on in facebook were
in Google rather where they were trying
their best to solve a problem and it
looks really bad when you put it this
way but there's you know if you knew the
whole story would be okay I could
imagine a way where they're being really
bad so you have to keep in mind you
don't know everything when you're
judging it even without knowing
everything there's something you can do
and when I was talking to my friend who
works in YouTube earlier today he was
saying something it was very much in
line with what Brian you were saying
about we don't know what we're doing the
companies are responding to punches left
and right they don't have a policy here
and because of that they're moved a lot
by the wind what's in the news what
they're getting a lot of heat on they're
trying to avoid that heat and without
knowing if Facebook is sort of you know
scheming against you
we can know that there is reason to be
worried about your content about the
content of other people we care about on
the platform and we can know that a loud
cry of we want to make sure Reubens not
de monetize we want to make sure he
stays on this platform and likewise for
other other companies that you or other
content creators you care about allowed
up cry about that could really make a
difference so I don't know what the
email address people could write to but
if everybody writes to rights to YouTube
now support at YouTube or whatever
everyone watching this and says I saw
this thing about people have an eye on
dave rubin specially at youtube i want
you to know I love dave rubin I don't
want anything done to him I don't want
him cancelled I'll stop watching and
they get hundreds of thousands of emails
or even thousands of emails today that
would be fine I don't I believe it or
not actually although I do think that
ultimately is the right thing that if we
make enough noise and that's why I'm
always talking about this that we can
change things with a million-plus
subscribers and being on YouTube now for
you know six or seven years I literally
don't have an email address of anyone at
YouTube I cannot I invited Susan which
wiki I think is her name is the CEO I
invited her on the show again today so
we'll see if we can move on some of that
we're gonna we've done about an hour or
so here so far we're gonna do about a
half hour of Q&A there's a mic I think
right over there
and if you guys disagree with us on
anything I would prefer that you guys go
to the front of the line so if you have
any real disagreements please just jump
up there right now and before we do that
make some noise for these three
gentlemen and for that all
radical Milton Friedman turned so many
of you into far-right personalities I
think there might be two microphones or
there's at least one right over there
and and we'll do this for a half hour or
45 minutes or so so try to keep it
somewhat brief and we'll get to as many
as possible hi thank you for coming my
question is real quick locate free
marketeers capitalist individualist
today what should they focus on sure
they focus on the philosophy of
capitalism or the economics in the
history like the Milton Friedman day in
Hayek and von Mises to get the ideas out
there and change the culture for the
better I mean I think you have to focus
on the philosophy as the foundation but
you better be able to answer some of the
economic and historical questions as
well so it's not easy but that which
makes us unique is Objectivist is focus
on the philosophy on the morality of
capitalism on why it's a just system but
you also have to know the other stuff as
well yeah I would say very briefly it
has to be both which is exactly why I
wanted to do this panel tonight which we
changed the topic just two days ago
before this Veritas thing came out
because what I wanted to do tonight was
do something that would take the
philosophy that you guys care about that
I've talked about on the show with you
before and go well what it's not just at
this level where we can think about it
but it's sort of what you said you're on
there that well now you've got these
principles they're gonna be hard to
defend we'll defend them now so I think
I think it's probably a little bit about
thank you this question is for Dave I
really appreciate your stand on free
speech and your migration toward
classical liberalism but help me
understand
I fail to see how you can compromise on
the principles of individual inelia
bolides
life liberty property and pursuit of
happiness no matter how your noble cause
is whether you want to provide education
medical care to the poor or whatever
don't you think that those should be
voluntary and that once you allow
forceful redistribution no matter how
noble
your goal is you have a banded the most
basic individual political right yes
yeah so it's a great question this is
something that I think about all the
time I'm actually in the in the last 20%
of writing my first book right now and
I've really been focusing on this of
sort of these moments where for somebody
that is a truly small government guy
that believes in liberty and the
individual when are those brief moments
that that government can be involved I
think this is where I differ with some
of the guys on the panel and some of you
guys here that I do see some more some
more broad uses for government they're
pretty rare look I'm a I'm a product of
public education from elementary school
junior high high school I went to State
University of New York at Binghamton I
believe that education is something the
state can provide that being said I
believe in charter schools I believe in
school choice and as much opportunity as
as possible for parents to choose where
they want to send their children to I
think there are there are outlier cases
you know I think that well I know you
guys don't specifically describe
yourselves as libertarian I sort of look
at the class of a liberal philosophy as
sort of a slightly more realistic
version of libertarianism and we can
disagree on the edges or we could
disagree sort of at the high-level
philosophic places really are we forcing
anyone to do this or that and you know
does the state ever over encroach well
it does all the time we know that but I
think you have to pick out some things
that are sort of realistic within a
framework of we're a country that's
existed you know 200 plus years and
we're trying to manage as I said before
300 plus million people and that it's
not gonna always be exactly as you want
and sometimes maybe there is a little
more use for government so I sort of I
have a little bit of I would say a
disconnect between what I sort of
believe purely at a philosophical level
and what I just think is is real politic
I think it's a great question this is
what I Ron said check your premises
because once you open that slippery
slope there's no ending
look I would say this I believe me I get
it I would say more than anything else
in the last couple years by talking
about these ideas the way that I have
and have had having people like your on
on who quite literally when when I
finished up my first interview with
Joran I'm sure some of you know this
I left the network I was at they had
been asking a lot more of us and I had
this whole conversation about rational
self-interest and I got up and I walked
into the control room and I resigned
right there so I yeah so trust me I I
get it I get it and these are these are
conversations that I'll always be
thrilled to be to be part of whether we
always get completely locked up on
everything is actually irrelevant to me
as long as we can keep doing it I have a
question for you Dave Jordan Pearson
recently had Joe Rogan on his podcast
and in last time inter sewed brought up
teased out think spot so I'm hoping you
can elaborate your involvement in that
and what you hope it actually turns out
to be yeah so I actually didn't see all
of that but I know that Jordan did
mention it while I was talking to Joe I
can't actually say too much for a couple
insider reasons at the moment because
the platform hasn't been fully launched
yet and it's it's just going into beta
right now but let me say this if anyone
can solve this on a platform front I
just spent a year and a half traveling
the world with Jordan and we did
something like 120 stops in you know a
hundred cities and almost 20 countries
and when I the way that I have seen this
guy changed the world because of the
ideas that he believes in which are
rooted in individualism and Liberty and
I know he has a difference let's say on
religious value then maybe you guys have
if anyone can fix some of this stuff I
think he is the right guy to do it and I
think what we would all agree on here is
let's just get more platforms up let's
get more whatever it is whatever the
alternatives whatever Brian's working on
some of the other things I'm doing let's
just get more of these things out there
let's keep testing the market and
something something we'll fix but
there'll be more answers to that in the
next couple weeks thank you
my question has to do with the values
and attitudes of the CEOs of companies
like Google its subsidiary YouTube or
any others if I were a CEO of such a
company and someone said you know you
really need to start suppressing certain
opinions and not others my immediate
reaction would be what about our
reputation what about our integrity
isn't that an important value we hold
ourselves out to be fair and open to all
and we're not isn't it going to be
terribly embarrassing to us one example
that comes to my mind is covered news
coverage of the Soviet Union in the
1930s this is the New York Times sent up
a communist sympathizer if not an actual
communist walter durante and he
whitewashed the mass starvation deaths
imprisonment and mass murder and he
wasn't the only one presumably when that
came out and if they come out that
guarantee had done that it damages the
new york times wouldn't it damage
YouTube that they become a guy like
Dennis Prager who I happen not to like
but he he's not advocating murder and
let other people you know pretty much
say what they want yeah as the insider
that's probably for you yeah I mean yeah
I think you know speaking about mark in
particular here at Facebook
I think he's caught in a bit of a bind
where on one hand for many years and I
think this continues to be true he does
actually care deeply about freedom of
speech and he is I think within Facebook
one of the biggest advocates pushing for
a diversity of perspective both inside
the company and on the platform so I
think he believes that that he wants
that on the other hand you know this is
what we talked about earlier with I
don't think he fully understands why he
ought to be as be proud of what Facebook
is as he as something he's created for
the world and something that he should
stand
straight and up tall about and so he's
got a bit of a guilt complex so they
think about the success that the
companies experience and that that's
meant to him and so it's made him
particularly sensitive about people and
groups that you know appeal to him and
the company for being you know hurt in
in one way or another and so you know I
think that's one piece of it is that
there's a lot of compromise I think that
happens between waffling between those
two and the other piece though is that
again Facebook was not created to be a
platform for ideas it was created to be
a place where you could become closer
with your friends and family and the
organizations later the organizations
that you care about and what that means
what that way if you really think deeply
about that mission keeping people safe
now safe is a very broad word but
keeping people safe where they feel like
this is a a safe place for them to
become closer and be their authentic
selves that's a really important part of
that mission and to the extent that
Facebook is not primarily about being a
platform for the free expression or free
exchange of ideas and it's primarily
about being a place where you can be
yourself and become closer to the people
you care about safety often wins as a
result of that and so when people come
to mark and into Facebook and they're
saying I feel unsafe because of this or
or you know I don't feel like I can be
myself on this platform because I'm
being you know people are saying this or
that that's I think the situation where
you know safety starts to win freedom of
speech starts to lose within the
platform and you know then that's
eventually led me to my perspective that
that that's not really what Facebook is
about it's not a a marketplace of ideas
and quickly to jump on that you know I'm
sure many of you guys saw when Jack
Dorsey from Twitter was on Joe Rogan's
podcast and he brought the the head of
Terms of Service I'm blanking on on her
name and Joe brought Tim Poole
and Tim is a spectacular journalist and
activist a real journalist which there's
very few of these days and basically Joe
kicked the the pointed questions to Tim
and it was very clear that Jack and I I
don't believe him to be an evil person
it was basically that he was sort of in
over his head which is sort of what
you're talking about with Mark they
created something and then it became
something else and really at the end I
think Jack realized well why even have
these conversations because it's almost
impossible to placate everybody so
instead they just sort of they they they
basically check out which is why I'm not
holding my breath for Susan from YouTube
there's a mammoth contradiction in this
discussion the contradiction is the
alleged problem is that some private
business owners are shutting off certain
people such as you Dave and others for
no good reason but the solution that's
being discussed by some people I don't
know about the people here but some
people let's bring in the government to
have a really good fair open discussion
let's have Nancy Pelosi or Donald Trump
decide what should be heard by the
people because they will not shut down
Dave Rubin in your own brook they will
have all the right ideas presented
that's a mammoth contradiction isn't it
well the only thing I would trust Nancy
Pelosi with is what drink to order me at
the bar but that was to mean I thought
you guys are like that
yes well there's a huge contradiction I
think I think all right we're addressing
that yeah yeah I know absolutely I mean
they the government is the last place
you want to go to decide who should be
on a platform one who shouldn't be on a
platform on what is reasonable speech
and the idea that these private
companies are being influenced let's say
by a leftist ideology and that politics
will not be foolish by leftist ideology
is absurd I mean the in in in in
political correctness and and all of
that I mean politics is filled with that
it's filled with that more so than any
other realm so the idea of bringing
those people in is is is bizarre to me
because because they're the worst
they're the worst offenders and we've
already seen it so yeah in a way it's
something new it's new with the internet
but we've already seen this happen and
this is an Objectivist comforta I'm Ram
was writing about this in the 60s and in
the 60s we had a worry that the TV news
wasn't fair that some people owned too
many newspaper companies so the op-eds
were all slanted in their favor and the
Kennedy administration was trying to use
antitrust to break up major media
companies because they were worried
about precisely the same thing people
are worried about now with you know is
Google too big or whatever and we had
the FCC being used to really kind of
constrain what points of view were
allowed on the air so that it could be
quote fair on television and radio and
as a result of that you had particularly
the FCC thing which succeeded the
antitrust against newspapers didn't you
had decades of damn monotonous nobody
saying anything you know the the range
of points of view that were discussed
were tremendously constricting you had
some of those FCC rules eliminated in I
guess the early 80s or late 70s that's
what allowed
talk radio to a kind of platform where
there were a lot of right-wing voices
where they were mostly left-wing voices
on the other stations now we have this
oasis of freedom on the Internet where
suddenly a wide range of views that
aren't right or left as you
traditionally think of them that are
coming out
the blue people like you people like
petersen in Iran getting more of a voice
and whoever else
the Tim Poole Joe Rogan all these kind
of voices coming up new ideas being
heard people being discussed and at the
first hitch at the first time there are
some bots or something and it may be
excuses the baby and elections goes
weird differently than people want or
too many people are insulted or the
companies overreact to that maybe by
shutting down some account they should
at the first hinge the whole damn
country is calling to call the guns in
to bring us back to the nineteen fifties
right to shut down the conversation to
put force on the mind this is wrong and
it's not gonna solve anything it's gonna
kill the goose that's laying the golden
eggs we hear the golden egg is the
opportunity to spread new ideas it's
killing the freedom of the mind
[Music]
so let's say the government does step in
in a mixed economy there are limited
circumstances where it's acceptable to
take unearned money from the government
if YouTube freely chooses to be
monetized someone like Dave should he
feel comfortable accepting money from
them knowing it's because they're being
coerced and how do we think about the
creators whose content has been promoted
instead in the meantime should we be
comfortable with them losing that income
so it gets diverted back to him I mean I
would say on the on the personal level
this is why everyone has to make the
choices that are right for themselves
and I think if you do what's right for
you you can sort of illuminate the path
to figuring out what's right for other
people so for example I'm sure many of
you guys saw this back in in December
January patreon made a couple moves
related to free speech with a guy by the
name of Carl Benjamin aka Sargon of
Akkad on YouTube where he said some
language not even on their platform not
even on his own YouTube channel it was
on someone else's YouTube channel they
didn't like the language that he used
although it was out of context and they
booted him off the platform and Jordan
Peterson myself Sam Harris and a few
other people we had the luxury because
we're doing okay of saying you know what
we're gonna make a principled stand
right now and we're gonna we're gonna
leave the platform and then I moved
everything over to my website Sam did
the same to his Jordan did so a few
other moves and through that actually
our monthly subscriptions went up
because I think we live in a time of a
sort of a sort of bravery deficit and I
think if you show people that you will
do the right thing and occasionally take
some risks I mean you know I'm not the
greatest businessman in the world but
I'm pretty sure a normal businessman
doesn't voluntarily give up 70% of their
company's revenue but that's what we did
and I found out about two days later
that we were up by 30% so I think if you
do what's right yeah
so I think if you do what's right for
you you will show other people that they
can do the right thing
listen it would be my preference if all
of you guys walk out of here right now
and you go to Dave Rubin calm slash
donate and and so and subscribe monthly
for whatever the amount is I would
gladly just just out of principle I
would I mean I think about it every day
I would love to shut ads off on YouTube
altogether
I can't do it right now it's just not
it's just not a functioning I have
full-time and part-time employees and
insurance and all of those things I
can't do it right now but but we're
working on some of the solutions and
Brian's working on some and you know I'm
sure you guys are working on some at
least just just in your mind if nowhere
else but some of those solutions will
will come and then people will be able
to do sort of what's right what's right
for them thanks for showing that first
video I just wish they didn't ask my
voice a little better can you talk about
how when trust Busters are making us all
scared of monopolies how they narrow the
market artificially to get us hyped up
about it when the market is actually
bigger and is that the case here I'm not
sure if your voice I'm not trying to
spit the question if you're worried but
yeah it is when people want to claim
there's a monopoly for antitrust purpose
they have a artificially narrow view of
what the industry is or what the
products are yeah I mean the whole idea
of monopolies is is is a wrong concept
it's it's the monopolies as things that
granted by the government and where the
government creates protection for an
industry that's where the term comes
from historically and that's what it
refers to in a free market or even in a
semi free market like I think we have in
technology there is no such thing as
monopolies and in you you know you we've
got competition right now and the fact
that there are people working on
potential alternatives suggests that the
no real barriers to entry the only be
barrier to entry is the marketplace is
can you take market share from Facebook
and you take
Malka shay from youtube and the other
platforms but you know i don't have time
to get into the whole Monopoly history
here I've got plenty of videos on it on
youtube so go watch them but hey Dave
can't do self-promotion I don't he
little bit do the joke there it was so
obvious so but but monopolies don't
exist in in even a semi free market and
the substitute products to the products
that seem to be have be monopolized
often things that we can't even imagine
often things we don't know and often
things we don't know a coming right so
who competed rockefeller out of his
so-called monopoly over kerosene Thomas
Edison right so Thomas Edison but who
would have thought electricity would
kill is a competition to oil but it was
in a sense and and you that's the beauty
of marketplaces you you leave them alone
and it works that the model is the
practical if it's wrong to use force to
break up a company it's also from a
practical perspective it's it's gonna
work out worse if you if you intervene
one of the things I can all just add to
that one of the things I can say when
thinking about competing with a company
like Facebook and I say this is somebody
who's now sort of in that space with
what I'm building but also spent many
years watching Facebook compete from the
inside is that they look like monopolies
because from the outside when you try to
compete with them by copying them it
never works like you'll never get market
share that way and so you've got to
think about it from that perspective if
you're gonna try to compete with with
with a company that has massive market
share you actually have to solve a
problem in a profoundly different way in
a way that users actually care about
enough to migrate and you don't do that
by cloning you know the incumbent in the
market and doing something a little bit
different and so what I can say about
you know what we're building now which
is called thoughtful by the way and go
to thoughtful dot community if you want
to hear more about this in the future
what we're building now you know what
we're not doing is cloning Facebook or
YouTube and saying but we're not going
to do censorship that's not a good
product that doesn't get at the
fundamental reason that people are upset
about not having access to a diversity
of perspectives the way we look at this
what we want to do is make it easy to
find the best thinking on issues that
are complicated that are controversial
that are crucial to your life the things
that would really better your life if
you could understand them but it's just
so damn hard to find the best
perspectives and the best thinking on
those issues that's a real problem and
to build that kind of service to build
something that actually helps you do
that not only does it look very
different than something like Facebook
or YouTube but it takes a while to
figure out I mean this is part of what
we got it you have to give it time you
have to make sure the market is capable
of producing something like that but
when when you if we you know if you
succeed at something like this later on
it doesn't look like you can you could
we're competing with a monopoly it looks
like you obviated them and that's often
the way it's looked in history I worked
with elite Silicon Valley executives and
VC executives for the past few years and
I think there's a lot of sinister ideas
in Silicon Valley in social media but I
think there's a mechanisms that that
mechanism that's being overlooked I
think that the entrepreneurs who run
these companies are bad thinkers and
they have bad ideas but I don't think
that's where the center sinister ideas
are it's actually the consultants and
advisers that they bring in to solve
these problems and they bring them in
from Stanford University and Harvard
University and the Obama administration
and future administrations and these are
where the really sinister ideas
originate in Silicon Valley and the CEOs
are vulnerable to them so that's the bad
news
I think the good news
that thinkers such as all of us
we're not duped by manipulation you can
hurt Dave Rubin and your own brooken
financially but it's not going to
silence the truth and and everybody
knows we're being manipulated who think
now uninformed people might be
manipulated but I'm optimistic to think
that those who matter who are going to
affect the culture in the long run
they're going to be victims who are
going to be wiped out and bankrupted all
you know along the way but the truth is
if we are aware that we're being
manipulated the games that Silicon
Valley is playing in this way are
ultimately going to all fail and better
ideas are going to prevail so I mean I
agree with your first point and it's my
point about the left in a sense winning
the intellectual battle and dominating
it TOEIC so high ground so when somebody
comes in from Stanford yeah what are
they gonna be they're gonna be
conventional thinkers which is now on
the left I'm not convinced about the
second point right so and it's true that
those who already know the stuff are not
gonna be manipulated but what about the
young kids who are just trying to find
new ideas and clearly YouTube is
throttling my channel so I'm getting to
fit and they have been since about
September that I'm not getting to as
many young people as I used to so
they're never gonna be close to these
ideas they're never gonna discover these
ideas and and and I think that's true of
Dave and I think that's true of a lot of
producers on YouTube the platforms can
indeed reduce our exposure reduce the
number of people that exposed us once
you exposed I think you find that you
know you know how to find us and you
know how to search it's that first
encounter that is being suppressed and
that's what worries me it's like yeah
once you discover Iran's books then you
read morning man but finding that first
book right and and if the schools won't
let Iran in which is not the case
luckily but if the schools are then
fewer people are gonna find that first
book and therefore fewer people are
going to be engaged
so first of all I wanted to command and
dr. Brooke for his very lucid comments
even though he's completely enough
outside air into the tech industry your
points were right on you were right on
point one thing which hit me as part of
this discussion is it seems like there
is a lack of understanding of the
engineering culture in some of these
companies so I'm just this is a question
for Dave Rubin how much time actually
have you spent seeing like the light you
know a day in the life of an engineer
because there's a there's a lot of
effort that goes into building these
platforms so it's it seems like there is
this conception of this like evil
engineer um tweaking the knobs that is
not so and on the flip side how much
time have you spent in the day of an
engineer at like say a defense company
so I've spent a decent amount of time
around engineers and developers just in
the last six months before that not much
I had you know James d'amore on who was
the the fired Google engineer and he
sort of enlightened me both on the show
and privately sort of how the Google
operation works and how you know the
engineers come up against the diversity
training people and all of those sort of
things I can tell you again without
saying too much on the tech side right
now that in the last six months since
since leaving patreon and starting to
work on some of these tech side things I
talked to engineers several engineers a
couple times a week and I'm starting to
learn that so when I used sort of the
analogy of you know there's someone in
there pushing a knob or something like
that of course I'm being slightly
sarcastic but there we know that there
are enough people I mean this is I would
say watch my my episode with James
d'amour we know that
these diversity memos and meetings they
have that these ideas then leak into all
of the hard sciences and the places
where the engineers are doing the real
work so of course of course I don't
think that the average engineer at
Google is trying to is trying to do
anything bad or anything like that but
we all have our own biases and when you
have a certain amount of power you might
do that and I would say either way
whether whether there are some bad ones
or not either way we know something is
faulty with these products right now and
that's why it's it's on us and everyone
in this room and watching this to figure
out what some of the alternatives are
all right we got we got four more we'll
try to do them kind of quick okay it's
it seems as if de monetizing and
throttling and deleting content by
YouTube and others is a bad business
model they're cutting their own income
by doing that and what I would like to
see for those of you doing a new a new
platform is to have rather than having
the company delete content that people
advertisers say I would like to
advertise on this channel so that they
could positively support the ideas and
the thinkers that they agree with well
just very briefly it's a little bit of
sort of just a technical way that they
do these ad buys where they're just
buying across the board and then there's
a couple keywords that they just spread
things to everybody but yes my
preference for sure if anyone's watching
this and wants to sponsor the Reuben
report I would much prefer that just a
cool coffee company or a wine company or
a sneaker company or clothing company
that just digs what I do I would much
prefer to have products that I directly
care about sponsor and then also them
take a little piece of that risk if
people think that what I'm doing is
controversial well maybe they'll put
their money where their mouth is and buy
products that support controversial
ideas so that that's just a little bit
of a different business model for those
guys one thing I could add to that as
well this is something that the the
marketplace needs to innovate on
- because you know what I know about
advertising is that advertisers are
allergic to controversy and I also know
that a free exchange of ideas you know
is controversy is endemic to a free
exchange of ideas those are really at
odds at a very fundamental level and so
yeah I mean when we're working on on
thinking through the business model of
this stuff we're very aware of that hi
thank you for the talk today certainly I
and our way in the room are very Pro
free-market my concern is if politics is
the gun in the middle of the room that
we're not going to grab what do you do
or is there concern that your opponent
is grabbing it and you know after if
Google is putting their thumb on the
scale already can the free market even
survive eight years of Bernie Sanders
right so are we playing a long game and
I agree in the long run the market will
solve all these problems that's I agree
with that but then you see Chase
Manhattan Bank you know
canceling accounts with no reasons and
there are other banks
that's a heavily regulated industry and
you know if Bernie Sanders is in there
for eight years with Google is there
concern that we're gonna lose what we
have because we're playing the long game
because they already have a gun in their
hand I want to let one of you guys hit
this but this is what I was trying to
say before about this idea that people
are gonna go okay you guys get it at the
idea level but the people that you're
fighting against are willing to do all
of the bad things that you will never do
the people were fighting against on
every side
if by side you mean Republicans and
Democrats Donald Trump is no free
marketer he's no fan of free speech he
tweets about wanting to - I mean he
literally tweets about wanting to
prosecute comedy shows that make fun of
him no one's done that I mean I can't
think of another president so I'm not
saying he's the worst ever on free
speech but he's not it's not like this
guy is gonna be good
free speech and we got to get him versus
sander and then who are Sandra's other
opponents in the Democratic well Warren
Warren's wants to I mean it's not like
there's some candidate on the horizon
right now who's really better than the
other ones on this what we have to make
known if we want there to be better
candidates in the near future is that
all of these options are the same and
equally unacceptable and which thug with
a gun starts shooting it at people
speaking this one or that one and he
gets your left ear or your right ear
that is no different there but your
justice dead or crippled either way we
have things we can do to support freedom
on these platforms we can make it known
that we're against candidates who want
to regulate this industry we can judge
once we have two candidates to vote for
right which one is a little bit better
than the other on that word in this
position we don't know whether
Republican or the Democrat will be the
worst they're both going to be bad we
can make it known why we're voting from
one of the other or why we're abstaining
and we can do a lot in the meantime to
support the people who are trying to
build other platforms to get on those
other platforms to talk to these
companies about what we want out of them
to protest if we're afraid that they're
gonna cancel a channel we want there are
practical take steps we could take but
joining the struggle to grab the gun
with other people who want to point it
at us is not going to save us and all
the other factions that want to grab the
gun all the ones that are trying to
point it are trying to point it at us
are trying to point it out the mind of
the people who want to speak freely and
you can't get enough struggle over who
grabbing the gun unless you've got
people who are going to use it to
protect rights not thwart them at least
who are going to be a little bit better
than the other guy on it and right now
we don't know which side is better it's
not always the same side election after
election but it's a broad I think it's
even broader than that you don't say
freedom by denying it by rejecting it by
using force unless you're ready for a
revolution
you want to grab I've said this before
on a platform with Oh card you want to
go start a revolution and break into the
Armory's and get guns and really fight
it let's talk right I'm not advocating
for that but let's let's call it what it
is but you don't you know when when
George Bush said in 2008 I'm I'm
rejecting I'm doing all these
anti-capitalist things to save
capitalism did any of us believe it no
you know I'm gonna break up I'm gonna
deny Google and microsites in order to
save capitalism and say free speech
it's that possible is that even
conceivably possible because the left
plays dirty because the left is willing
to use the power of government in order
to defend the idea that government
shouldn't use force we can't use the
government's force you don't use the
government's force in order to you know
deny it force it's a complete
contradiction you don't save capitalism
by rejecting capitalism you don't say
freedom by rejecting freedom you don't
say free speech by rejecting free speech
we believe in freedom and this is the
point I made a day before this is where
the rubber hits the road if we don't
defend freedom now when are we going to
do it if we don't stand up for free
speech in the face of the challenge
we've got right now when are we gonna do
it it's now that everything's at stake
heaviness and
and that is not a sacrifice for
principle it's not a sacrifice of prince
we have a principle and we're willing to
die for it we can't live without it
and it's in it's it's it's if you look
at there if you look at some people on
the right and I've mentioned this first
things article and I mentioned it again
they're conservative some first things
who are saying now we need a violate the
principles of free markets in order to
save us from the left we need to violate
that we need the cultures are model
enough so we need to impose more
authoritarianism in order to save us on
the Left cultural nihilism we need to
violate the principles of freedom to
make us what to make us a Fallot Aryan
that's what ultimately this all leads to
you do not achieve freedom by force
unless again it's really by force unless
it's revolution and then ok then the
gloves are often let's go do it you know
I've a little bit of training so so I
get that like I can help you guys out
yeah white shorts leave your on Brook is
ready for a revolution pooping all right
two more two more I thanks I'm going to
try and actually apply an oak on lesson
that I learned channel my inner Alex
Epstein do you think there's a better
way to frame this issue rather than and
I think you guys may have just touched
upon this so you know I could just move
on but is there a better way frame in
this issue than a sort of left versus
right or in terms of left first right
because we're just speaking personally
I'm you know I'm 39 year old
I'm just turned off by the wet first
right argument because it's meaningless
it's it's individuals versus the left
and right together so I'm just curious
if we've thought about kind of a better
way of attacking these problems because
I don't see the left/right argument as
being effective personally I think it's
it's individualism versus collectivism
what we should fight for is free speech
we should fight for free speech which
means no government intervention in the
issues of speech and no government
intervention in the marketplace for
ideas and no govern intervention in
these platforms and whether the
government is left right you know it
doesn't matter
collectivism and force have no place in
the marketplace and that doesn't mean
being some utopian who lets the perfect
be the enemy of the good and won't
settle for it if you're like Dave and I
disagree on some things about free
speech you're in favor of public schools
or at least you're more sympathetic
towards them I think that's a violation
of free speech but if I think of like
where Dave is on free speech versus
where Trump and Bernie Sanders are on
free speech it's clear like he's a lot
more for free speech than they are he's
pretty close to my view of it we can
argue about this thing and we can see if
we got the country to where Dave wants
it to be that would be huge progress and
if we got it to halfway to where Dave
wants it to be that would be huge
progress right so it's not that unless
you have the perfect you can't vote for
anyone don't vote for Trump or don't
vote for Sanders he's not 100% but you
have to have a view of what you're
aiming towards what freedom is and then
be able to see why the thing you're
supporting is closer to it and be
advocating not just for some abstract
ideal but for steps to get closer to it
so what are some steps to get closer to
it well the first one is free up these
tech companies stop regulation on them
stop the net neutrality laws that there
were and that was one good thing this
administration did right but think of
what the concrete steps are towards
freedom and especially notice concrete
steps they're being taken away from it
and make sure those don't get taken in
the name of freedom all right one more
abrazo on this is mostly for you Dave
but it almost certainly applies to you
as well you're on so there's a very
noisy minority of you know these
so-called authoritarian right or the far
right or the fascist right the kind of
people that use three parenthesis and
they use the same kind of rhetoric about
oh were this disenfranchised minority on
were subject to the to the persecution
of Facebook's and Google's algorithm and
you've kind of been forced to bear these
people as almost fellow travelers
because they're saying something that's
very similar how is that affected your
ability to communicate
for what you're fighting for having to
bear these people you know it's
interesting Jordan gets asked a similar
version of this question often in the
last year because you know some of the
what you know what are known as [ __ ]
posters or the the me makers and the
Pepe people and all of those things the
frogs and all that that there's a
certain element of them that kind of dig
what we're doing because even if they
they don't like us for some sort of
identity reason they like that we're
fighting for free speech or something
like that now a I would say it's really
hard to judge what these people really
are right it's really hard to go are
these people truly white nationalists or
neo-nazis or are they just [ __ ] posters
are they just kids who get at their
computer and tweet frogs at celebrities
so that they can go crazy I mean it
really is some version of that so it's a
little bit hard on that side but what I
would say just let's pretend that
there's a certain amount of them that
that really do exist if they're watching
my show and think I'm offering you know
safe quarter for any of those ideas that
are based on racism or collectivism in
any way I mean I would just say you're
watching the wrong show and you've got
this thing really kind of confused but
also I would say that the more for
someone like me that came from the left
that has more for I get what we're
saying here about the left/right thing
but that is more frustrations with
identity politics right now if we can
unfurl a little bit of the way that that
is so entrenched in media and academia
right now and with the tech companies
and all of that what's happening on the
right the version of that that you're
talking about really is a reaction to to
the craziness that it has exploded with
on the left and I feel like if we can if
we can unfurl a little bit of what's
going on with the left which is much
more mainstream and I think I've been
pretty effective at it that that portion
of it on the right whatever that is I
don't think it's a lot of people and I
don't think it has any institutional
power I don't think that it has real
political power I'm talking about some
sort of white nationalist thing or
anything like that and I think we'd be
able to kick them to the curb where
where those ideas belong so it's on us
to do a little bit better job having
those conversations it's a great
question on that note guys thank you
very much for being part of this make
some noise for the people at home
[Applause]
and thank you to my panelists and and I
do want to just I want to say one other
thing which is that I want to just be
very very clear not really not for you
guys in the room but for the people that
are watching this at home that will
anything that I do with a RI tall and
and your own and everybody else they we
never go through what I'm gonna do
sometimes they'll say ah maybe you want
to focus on this or focus on that they
say go up there and do whatever you want
to do it does not matter what we agree
on it does not matter what we disagree
on and for that for nothing else but
that I will keep doing these things as
long as they'll invite me and I always
find you guys to be a great audience so
thanks again and having the night
everybody all right
[Applause]
[Music]